[музика]
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами
майстерня творчості пані слові та
істинки сьогодні ми будемо вчитися щось
малювати Давайте я вам покажу що це може
бути і ви здогадаєтесь ось так він не
влізе помаленьку лізе і несе на совість
свою хатинку що це може бути черепаха
це може бути черепаха але це дещо
менш так лізе і може сидіти на листочках
Равлик ми з вами зараз будемо робити
равлика так для цього нам буде потрібен
просто листок паперу олівець ручка
фломастер будь що що маєте
чим можна писати Так будь-що чи можна
писати і ми зараз спробуємо зробити
равлика Отож починаємо з того що малюємо
ось таку мордочку
знаєш ніби буква S
Добре тепер ми тут трішки продовжуємо
лінію верхню
добре
тягнемо вниз
Тепер продовжуємо ніби шию ще одну лінію
добре І тепер робимо велику хатку
всередині друзі малюємо закарлючку
кожного своя
добре І тепер нам потрібно намалювати
ріжки так
правила Равлик вистав ріжки
добре очі
і ротик
супер істинку Покажи свій малюнок друзям
Ось так вийшло дуже гарно
будемо закінчувати
па па друзі па-па
[музика]
Усім привіт з вами пані Софія і мої
помічники Зайченя хромчик і юстинка
тримайте щенятко Ну що ж будемо сьогодні
слухати наступну історію із книги про
песика чапу
І от у цій книзі є історія про хлопчика
А історія наша називається хто
найважливіший цікаво правда ну ми
починати
у хлопчика антося є багато іграшок якось
ті іграшки засперечалися хто з них
найважливіший ну справді цікаво давайте
дізнаємося ми найважливіші сказали
машинки А хто нами грається той може
гарним водієм стати цікаво
Ні ми
засперечались кубики бо ми допоможемо
антосеві стати будівельником
це теж важливо будувати треба вміти далі
за сперечався м'яч Ні я найважливіший
якщо Антось гратиме у футбол то виросте
славнозвісним футболістом не треба
футболіста
обурилось іграшкове піаніно краще Хай
Антось буде музикантом
музику Ми теж любимо слухати Це теж
цікаво та що там ви всі гордо мовив
робот з моєю допомогою Антось стане
інженером інженер це хто
це малята така професія
інженер - це людина яка займається
створенням і обслуговуванням різних
технічних пристроїв цю людину ще
називають винахідник інженер або
винахідник слухав слухав Котик Мурчик цю
суперечку і каже
ви знаєте іграшки усі ви потрібні
та без книжки жодна із цих мрій не
здійсниться
От тому і читає хлопчик Антось щодня
[музика]
яка історія трапилася з антосами тобто
усі іграшки
сперечалися що вони найважливіші Але щоб
стати музикантом будівельником або
інженером потрібно багато вчитися читати
книжки звісно Дякую юстинко за допомогою
книг ми можемо здобувати нові знання Ми
можемо дізнатися щось нове цікаве і
головне корисне тож друзі Я бажаю вам
багато читати Можливо хтось із вас вже
вміє читати той може це робити сам або
можете слухати різні історії
скільки ми вже з вами історії дізналися
Я думаю вам цікаво
попереду нас чекають ще багато історій
ну а зараз ми будемо прощатися З вами
була пані Софія і мої помічники юстинка
і зайченя хрумчик до нових зустрічей
папа па-па
[музика]